I think porn has really changed the game  you know out of the gate now sex is much  kinkier I think is a porn out of the  gate now it's like choking spitting  finger up the butt which is weird  because these are all things my older  brother did to torment me  it's all the same [ __ ] we've just taken  bowling out of the playground brought in  the bedroom I got my girl on top now I'm  like Indian sunburn  seriously you go to a schoolyard during  recess some kids holding a girl down  pulling her hair calling her names I'm  like man he's good  I'm taking notes to get back to your  girl she's like wow where'd you learn  that I'm like a couple of third graders  actually but don't worry I like red wine  [Music]